inside your body right now white blood
cells are moving through your tissues on
the hunt for pathogens but this cell is
in a petri dish in a lab in Austria
where researchers have been putting
white blood cells through a variety of
obstacle courses these experiments are
designed to reveal the secrets of their
impressively fast locomotion and
understanding how these immune cells
speed through the body could help reveal
how cancer cells move and spread these
neutrophils are racing through a maze
they're attracted to a chemical at the
other end and by sensing the chemical
gradient they can pick the shortest path
but the inside of your body isn't like a
maze with a choice of uniform pathways
instead immune cells need to be able to
squeeze through gaps between tissue
cells and pick the best route in a new
experiment this dendritic cell is given
a choice of four paths of different
widths it probes the different options
before picking the widest path allowing
it to move faster than it could through
a narrower channel this ability to sense
the size of gaps means that cells moving
through the body can avoid dense areas
and find the fastest routes rather than
just the shortest ones
when trying out different options these
cells position the big bulky nucleus
near the front if the nucleus fits the
rest of the cell will - this ensures the
nucleus doesn't get damaged squeezing
through to narrow a gap once the cell
has decided on a path the other
protruding probes are retracted using a
kind of internal cellular skeleton made
of microtubules if these microtubules
are disrupted so that they can't retract
as has been done here the cell will pull
itself apart cancer researchers are
particularly interested in understanding
the mechanisms of immune cell locomotion
tumor cells may activate these same
systems when they start to metastasize
allowing them to move through tissues so
understanding this sophisticated
locomotion of white blood cells like
these could help scientists stop cancers
spreading around the body
you
[Music]